hallo mein name ist luca und ich sehe
aus wie eine leiche und bin ich so blass
ist aber auch egal bei der lieben
freunde wir spielen heute google juli
wird das ausgespannt
google steht ja ja das hier ist google
flut wir haben hier vier verschiedene
kategorien und zwar culture also kultur
people also menschen namens also namen
und questions also fragen wir können uns
eine dieser kategorien aussuchen und
dann gibt uns diese website einen satz
vor
seinen namen ein begriff und wir müssen
erraten was google auto kompletten würde
ein simples beispiel wichtig hier auf
den namen und hier steht barbara
schöneberger barbara schöneberger kann
ich mir vorstellen dass
ich
[Musik]
ist es nicht ein lied oder so verdammt
ich hab nur noch zwei gäste ist das
anders
barbara vielleicht gibt's ja noch eine
barbara naja ok gibt es nicht barbara
ney vielleicht harry calvin wooten wo
ich kenne keine einzige von denen das
war jetzt auf jeden fall die erste von
drei runden wenn ich perry ein gegeben
hätte hätte ich 10.000 punkte bekommen
wenn ich beispielsweise boxer ein
gegeben hätte hätte ich 2000 punkte
willkommen allerdings klicken wir direkt
auf next round thomas ich denke direkt
an gottschalk das ist allerdings
natürlich eine amerikanische website das
heißt ich war es unfassbar thomas müller
gebe ich einfach mal ein wird auch nicht
erkannten müller vielleicht auch nicht
als wenn ich jetzt hier im beispiel
schon so beschissen bin donnerstag gibt
es doch auch noch ne pommes de train
okay war mir allerdings nur noch schon
zur letzten finalen runde runde drei von
dreizehn darwin wird er so geschrieben
[Musik]
charles leclerc gibt's auch das ist ein
rennfahrer damit auch das hätte ich auf
keinen fall gedacht prinz vielleicht
heißt ja nicht prince charles ich habe
keine ahnung was sie noch einen geben
soll ich gebe wie der name ein
allerdings ist es auch nicht richtig
charles charly vielleicht gibt's den
jahren als bronson kenne ich noch
allerdings war das jetzt das erste spiel
das heute gemacht haben ja mein score
von 5.000 das ist ziemlich beschissen
schicken allerdings nun auf questions
das finde ich eigentlich am
interessantesten
ken block b
ich hab was reck nennt durch den bürgern
seinen kopf keine ahnung ob das okay ich
weiß dass ich schwanger werden können
das hätte doch be at home loan schreibe
ich mal noch das verändern eine kapelle
dobby in kauf
ich passe das sieht head of being the
passengers sieht ich glaube dass es zu
lange alltag lustig wie genötigt
schicken
sorry leute aber wer googelt denn bitte
caddoc bee-präsident ja ok donald trump
us ausgeschafft machen allerdings direkt
weiter mit der nächsten runde und zwar
ist das tape safe vor
also duct tape ist einfach der englische
begriffe klebeband von daher ist duct
tape safe vor mir fällt überhaupt nichts
1 begeht
ich denke daran dass man irgendwelche
lebensmittelverpackungen mit klebeband
wieder verschließt ob das sicher ist im
ok das macht überhaupt keinen sinn luca
ich gebe jetzt einfach irgendein scheiß
ja eigentlich will die lösung einfach
wissen text red dot wäre das einzige was
noch hätte kommen können aber alles
andere hier sind einfach nur tiere also
das verstehe ich wieder überhaupt nicht
ähnlich ticken aixtron djx sexy ist
ich habe keine ahnung what exactly ist
black hole schreibe ich einfach mal ob
wir nicht
what exactly ist live google live
webinar exit okay da das ist hätte ich
auch drauf kommen können synco de mayo
ist das nicht ein schauspiel synco de
mayo ist ein mexikanischer feiertag
naja haben wir diese runde also auch mit
5.000 punkten abgehakt das war wieder
richtig beschissen immer nun einfach mal
in die kategorie people und zwei failed
also levels ist das englische abitur
eilfeld college vielleicht okay okay das
ist richtig eilfeld at love kann ich mir
auch noch schreiben erzählt relation
relationship passt auch nicht
bohrtests vielleicht metlife ja klar
okay super everything marriage by
joblinge dort mein alter ich es kind
google denn das meeting auf potato genau
das würde ich auch google nächste runde
freunde ich denke mal drauf in mexiko
word for love bord
konkret wenn jemand schon googelt was
ist das mexikanische wort für ein
anderes wort dann muss etwas sein was
einen wirklich in dem moment sehr
interessiert also ja kontrakte müssen
eigentlich richtig sein
mexican word for the day be ok ok mid hh
was heißt durchfahrt auf mexikanischen
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche touristen im
urlaub gegoogelt also anders kann ich
mir das nicht erklären warum allerdings
nun auch in dieser kategorie zur letzten
runde und zwar my car is broken mai
christstollen er ist so michael ist
expensive ach du scheiße wie die
mannschaft die ganze sache nicht
gekommen liegt shaking overhead im
smoking total missing leaking motto no
turning und ich gebe so was ein wie
expensive wer googelt luca wer wer
googelt bitte mein auto ist euer land
wie komme ich denn noch so eine scheiße
wir haben mal wieder nur 5.000 punkte
hingekriegt geil ich bin richtig gut
darin machen allerdings nur noch ein
spiel in der kategorie kalt da ist der
erste satz star wars ist
great star wars bett star wars ist und
wie also vielleicht dies für okay
in der nächsten runde haben wir den satz
the way to the moon and back okay das
ist der romantische wieder voll
verschissen ich finde dieses spiel mega
mega geil mega interessant aber ich bin
halt wirklich echt ziemlich scheiße das
tut mir wirklich leid wesel runde ist
taylor swift geld gebe ich einfach mal
eine ok wird nicht gegoogelt ist taylor
swift in aliens safenet dass google doch
voll viele leute auf stars so aliens
sind ist taylor swift engagement ist
taylor swift dorf nij
die dating zwingel wie kann ich denn
darauf nicht kommt 12.000 punkte
meine damen und herren das er war bisher
meine beste runde die ich will aber die
sagen wir machen doch mal eine people
runden die fand ich eigentlich
interessantesten think i think the child
[Musik]
something i have to cancer
die kugeln denn leute richtige
hypochonder action ihr am start der
nächsten runde haben wir den satz isync
live is life is life world living judith
und ich denke nur an negative sachen new
yorkers armin okay new york apa great
mir fällt echt nichts mehr ein new
yorker star ruth k
[Musik]
[Applaus]
luca katze mir so eine medaille hier in
photoshop megageil also scheint es dass
hier wirklich sondern negative suche new
yorker es ist eine stadt im wandel und
die die stadt lebt und blabla
deswegen schreibe ich noch an friendly
fire will das ist das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr also new yorker ans
filmset ich schreibe ich noch ne neue
okay dass er wird okay wird es auch gut
als 22.000 punkte nur in dieser runde
ich bin ne geile ratte hebt dem video
einen daumen hoch wenn ihr auch eine
geile rate seit
[Musik]